worst dinner guests ever John Legend and
Chrissy Teigen are apparently the worst
dinner guests ever well at least
according to Kris Jenner I put the
cookbooks in back of her thinking that
she would pay some attention to me and
she promised me she'd help me cook
something and do you think she'd look at
me look at the cookbooks she's not going
to help in the kitchen here's what went
down the Kardashian family matriarch
invited Chrissy and John over to her
house for a holiday dinner but joked
that she was less than impressed by
their lack of manners she came over for
dinner tonight and I thought she would
teach me something like an appetizer
whatever a dessert and there she is just
like on the couch not paying any
attention to me at all
I would love to say that Chrissy made
this pie but nope she's
yep yep nope then she shared this clip
if they end up in her car I'm really
gonna be pissed
look at her look at her look at her yeah
that's Chrissy digging through the giant
white stockings on the mantle
she's stealing stuff out of our
stockings
it's wild like she comes over she looks
beautiful but she's taking stuff out of
our decorations like bad manners yes but
also I respect that move you know Chris
has those stockings filled with diamonds
and cash or puppies I mean she did just
give Chloe three puppies for her
birthday happy birthday Chloe three dogs
is wild to give somebody anyway back to
Chris's off-the-rails dinner party after
dinner wrapped up Chrissy and John
cuddled up together on the couch they're
making themselves way too comfortable
sure what's happening but they're
getting ready for bed it's ridiculous
so that's when John took off his pants
and hopped into bed with Chrissy for a
passionate makeout sesh yeah you heard
me
a pantless makeout sesh in kris Jenner's
bed is anyone else feeling wildly
uncomfortable worst dinner guests ever
yeah John and Chrissy didn't stop there
though in fact they went on a
full-fledged makeout tour there they are
pin the tub John still Sam's pants and
there they are rolling around on the
closet floor so how did this dinner
party from hell end with Chrissy
brushing her teeth seemingly with
Chris's toothbrush before leaving the
house carrying some expensive AF luggage
and when security tried to stop her well
this might just be payback though for
that time that Chris came over to
Chrissy and John's house for a Super
Bowl party in 2018 fell and broke their
coffee table if anyone's in the market
for a slightly used table the Christian
or actually just fell into it it's
customized excuse that it's customized
so sharp I can't believe it
maybe not a plane Chris what happened
over here okay it's official
John Crissy and Chris are the winners of
the Internet more of this content in
2020 please or better yet
can someone please give these three a
show I would definitely tune into that
of course you can count on et to bring
you all the latest John Chrissy and
Chris News so make sure to keep it
locked right here until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]